uh he gets hurt all the time the main
person that always gets hurt
for everything it's derrick rose
[Music]
i think you know better than anybody i
love games
so tell everybody it was me our mutual
friend jack harlow and one of gucci's
other friends we played heads up
and jack and i were partners we murdered
it wasn't even close i started doing
that in the nba bubble i would play
heads up with the guys and everybody
would compete to get the highest score
so
we're doing that now on this show so you
at least want to get a
somewhat respectable score
i'm ready put it more in the camera now
so i can see it
uh uh it's in oklahoma it's it's a team
in oklahoma um
um college team oklahoma what's the best
oklahoma sooners
oklahoma state cowboys okay no no skip
it skip it skip it give it
skip it yo skip it um
when you when you uh it's the opposite
of offense
defense yeah i need you to respond
quickly come on god damn
um not not
uh when you say your highness
what uh all right put it up put it up
skip it skip it skip it
give it um dang he was the he was the
best player that ever played for the
76ers
i mean allen iverson yeah come on
yes all right uh i can't explain this
one i can't explain this one go go down
go down because it
looks good yeah pass it uh he gets hurt
all the time
the main person that always gets hurt
for everything
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's derek rose okay i first want to say
the hoosiers are indiana oh okay my
fault i
was way and then
you couldn't get me to say doctor jack i
didn't know what timmy played budget he
was an old uber
you've been able to do some really cool
things
obviously one of the many great things
was being in the laugh now crylator
music video uh with drake lauder kd
odell how did that come to fruition and
were you like
what is happening
i had already been friends with
the boy for a minute man i think they
were looking for somebody to fill a role
of like a comedic role for that video
and he was just letting me know like yo
i think it would be perfect
you know i'm saying for the culture if
we come together and make this happen
and i was like damn
like you know of course like yeah i
definitely can't let that down but now
it was fun though i ain't gonna lie it
was it was real fun man
yeah and i know obviously you got to do
it with o'dell but you and odell are
also
already yeah you know it's crazy when we
when we were on the field
they were recording we was fooling
around the whole time but people don't
know odell's really funny as well all
odell does is goof around
like that's literally all that he does
yeah man people don't know
i think i think i tell oh all the time
he has he has a bright future in like in
hollywood
outside of even being famous for
football tell me the best
three phone numbers you have saved damn
i beat that
uh between justin bieber and jaden smith
i i have their numbers justin bieber he
wanted he had hit me about uh
being on could have been records uh this
live thing that i do
yes but he had facetimed me that same
night he had like a whole like
30-minute combo with me about like just
god and you know just
like just life in general and just
everything you know
he's been through and given me a little
bit of you know advice on different
things so he's actually a genuine i did
not expect that so when he faced it i'm
looking like what
yeah he's really what yeah dude i'm
talking about
he even started singing on the phone and
i'm like yo like what
what he's saying well it was some
angelic [ __ ] and i don't know what
it was we're going to run the basketball
category back
okay okay are you ready because i think
i think you could do a little better you
just had to warm up i think you need to
warm up
man it happens when you ah
you can't say the word all right skip
your your hand your hand what's the
thing around you
a ring a glove oh my god are you are you
nuts all right come on
skip it um skip it
skip it okay okay
he he's he's he's a white hooper and he
played for the phoenix suns
um jesus christ a
wristband a chess path okay
all right explain to me how i'm gonna
say hi team elijah
a lot of people maybe think okay you can
turn it on just for the internet
but this is actually how you act 24 7
all the time um so my question is
you sound like you've gotten annoyed
with me
but my question is like what's the
difference you know like what separates
the
people that are funny in real life and
the people that are just funny in a
specific you know
like area that's a good question damn i
think with stand-up comedians there's
like a huge difference which i'm getting
into now i think uh that just creates
the longevity of it if you can be funny
in real life i think it takes away the
whole like persona of
i'm gonna be this person when you see me
so have you done
stand-up yet or you're working i'm
actually working on a set right
now that's going to be there really
how we feeling about it i feel good i'm
still you know rubbing out the kinks and
the jinx
you know is it easier or harder than you
thought uh
harder because i think sometimes things
that you think in your head might not be
as funny when you say it
just just learning just learning so as
you continue to learn it's like okay
this isn't as easy as i thought i'm
trying to prove my works can be passed
you know just social media and like past
even
you know i work with a lot of like
different like music people like now i
feel like i have bigger goals to
accomplish like
working with people in movies and tv and
like more comedians getting involved
with
more live stuff you know that you've
probably been seeing me do you know but
um but yeah just just i feel like i
always
try to get that next thing i know with
your new podcast of mountain dew you'll
be talking
about hoops you'll be talking about
culture tell me that
intersection that's going to happen with
that podcast we got some
we got we got some heavy hitters coming
on there we got uh
bam uh miles turner my boy jamal murray
um [ __ ] you're making an appearance on
it so you know
you know you know it's so many people in
basketball that are just you know
talented and can do a lot of other stuff
so
it's good to shed light and to get to
know these people more personally you
know
we're gonna uh switch to your custom
decks we're gonna see how you do with
those
okay let me show you how to do this
close your eyes
there's a comedian um no no
that guy uh he talks like that
yes oh we our friend we played heads up
with him rapper tyler
yes um this is where we're from we just
talked about it
we're not counting yep um
this is another rapper oh i don't know
how to explain him though
okay so he is in okay uh
the best player in basketball what's his
name blank jordan ah
oh post malone
okay hold on skip this on rocky
no no no no it's okay okay no this is no
this is another rapper
he's from houston he's like he's a sick
oh oh oh travis scott
duh yes oh this is
kanye shoes what are they called yeezys
yes oh this is the hbcu
in dc oh uh howard
[Applause]
all right all right you're good you're
good i'm just playing we always indeed
show
by asking the guests some questions in a
rapid fire so it'll be quick you give me
the first thing that comes to your mind
okay
ready yes all right fill in the blank
drewski is legendary
oh i love it okay biggest w either
career or personal
i haven't got there yet i'll tell you
that worst habit
eating cereal man i'm addicted to eating
cereal but i'm like yo
i ain't eating a lot i was gonna say
last meal but i assume it might be
cereal
yeah okay um if you
don't like blank something is wrong with
you
if you don't like comedy something's
wrong with you okay seriously because
there's people out here that how do you
not like to laugh
advice to your younger self to just
stop caring what everybody thinks about
you and just do
just living your purpose that's one
thing i need to hear when i was like 18.
yeah and look at you now living in your
purpose yeah man
well drewski thank you uh for coming to
just playing playing some games with me
we gonna work on it but uh shout out to
you thank you
way to [ __ ] on me on the way out right
no i appreciate you man it's always good
chopping it up with you yes
always a pleasure hopefully see you soon